hey guys what's up this is andrew for
jensenses.com so in this video guys i'm
here to make an update after what
happened yesterday's guys on jamie we
broke out below the 87 level so let's
see what can happen now let's get into
it
[Music]
oh right guys daily time frame here we
go i did an update this on during the
weekend guys and i told you that 87 was
a support that might be broken guys once
again let me quickly re-explain why i
was worried about this level is like
whenever you are
coming to a support level for the third
time the third time is fine you know a
support can be tested multiple times but
the more it is tested the weaker it gets
remember that and whenever you arrive on
it with an increasing volume after a low
volume period it doesn't look good
alright so this was the worry i had and
unfortunately uh this is what happened
guys so
now look at that we have a breakout
below the 87 level that is an important
support level that has been tested once
twice in the recent past so
you know this information is very
important to make sure that this is a
level that whenever it's broken
some investors will change their mind
will invest differently for example guys
i know you don't like it but i
personally bought some protection
around 88 i was slow guys because there
is one hour delay in the us there was a
hour change and so i got trapped in that
and i was in australia at the open so i
bought protection but a bit late at 88.
so i'm still having my shots guys i'm
gonna hold forever that's for sure but
there is nothing wrong about buying some
protection so whatever i showed you that
guys in the previous video if you want
to have a look now it's not too late if
you want to get protection so let's
first uh try to understand what can
happen from here so like i said guys i
really don't like this area and i told
you that if we get in there it might be
brutal all right so right now i'm doing
this video two hours before market open
we have uh a pre-market uh up six
percent guys
all right jamie eight percent is about
to open at 84 guys all right
so
we are about to open around here
okay guys so it's good guys it's good
but
i mean it's too late to me you know why
is it too late because we have a
breakout on increasing volume after a
low volume period uh of an important
level
so bears and control guys bears in
control and i'm not saying we cannot go
above 87 i'm just saying that it's very
likely that you get rejected there right
that we get rejected at 87 and that we
go lower all right this is the usual
thing breakout retest and continuation
so this is unfortunately the most likely
scenario now if we're able to ride away
today close above 87
this would be a very nice victory of
balls let's see if it happens on higher
volume if yes
then we good all right so this is the
what we want to see but this is to me
for now not the preferred scenario what
is likely to happen is bears increase
the position here some bulls get out
guys at this levels and it's a level
where you can still buy some protections
i showed you guys i personally bought an
april uh 14th of april 75 put so it's
some protection you can get
not financial advice this is what i did
personally and i'm gonna unwind that uh
position on the way down so the question
we're having all right let's be honest
guys 40 seems very far right so maybe
it's unlikely we go there so we need to
find where are the other support levels
and then guys i want to talk i want to
show you guys something very very
exciting that i'm working on guys i'm
coming to that just in a sec so how do
you do when you want to find the targets
it's true on the way down it's through
on the way up you need four
supports on the way down all resistances
on the way up but if you don't have any
support in the area you want to trade
which is here between 87 and 40 how can
you do
we have all the tools to do that and you
guys have seen me using that many times
and you know that uh it's very efficient
whenever you don't have support or
resistance i'm talking of course guys
about fibonacci projections so let me
show you quickly how you do that
i've done that many times on the upside
i didn't do it many times on the
downside so let's do it together guys so
you use fibs fibs are here guys bam
trend based fib extension right
protection fibonacci protection ratios
you measure the wave you had last wave
so it's pretty obvious that it's from
here to here and that right now we are
doing here one more leg so there are
actually different things you can do you
can say a one two three four five i'm
having here an abc so this is not
any more
good this is not good anymore so either
you measure the total wave and you apply
the ratio to the top of the new wave
here and you check the golden number
ratio so 65 is one let me put it here
and then you have something around 45
but i have 40 already okay so i have
something around 65 now then i'm gonna
do it again because i don't know which
projection are we going to get from
which wave so i'm i i did the full wave
now i'm just going to do the one two
three four five okay so now only the
third wave
so i measure from the top of the third
wave to the bottom of it and i apply the
ratios here i'm doing it live with you
guys i didn't do it before and you try
to find
okay so we already had 86 87
doing that so i've done that before and
that's why i was saying that uh 87 was a
support level and here i don't have much
i have 57 the one-to-one relation you
you check for 61.8 38.2 50 so 50 is
above and one to one all right so this
is what we have using fib protection so
now we don't have any support using
trend lines but we have some support
using fails so maybe 57.65 so i
personally will unwind my protection
probably in this area between 57 and 65
and then if we drop lower i will buy
more shares so yeah now guys i want to
show you something amazing we are
working for a couple of weeks on our
nfts guys our uh the nfts that will be
the symbol of our channel so let me show
you quickly how it looks it's gonna be
the crypto bulls nft club guys so join
us follow us on twitter follow us on uh
discord you have the link in description
of this video this project is going to
be a killing let me quickly show you how
it looks so those are our crypto bulls
guys and it has been designed by my step
brother i guess it's a family thing and
i can show you right now guys how we are
still working of course on making many
variations to make it really looking
cool i'm gonna explain very soon what
the product is about because we have a
real project behind guys and a product
that is good for you you're gonna see
why so here are some variations and as i
know that you guys love bricks we have
of course included some bricks we have
like i said the channel spirit guys
we're still working on it but you're
gonna see some things like that like
stay close to shore of course guys
because you know it's representing the
the channel what else do we have
yeah we're gonna have a trader style
bull you know all of uh all things like
this guys and once again this product is
gonna be amazing it's about some crypto
arbitrage yes so we still need to check
if we're gonna uh meet the sec
requirements because what we want to do
is a very new guys we basically want to
use the fans to run a crypto arbitrage
and gabrielle who is with me in discord
made a ton of money doing that guys when
we had the crypto run last a few months
ago so whenever the cryptos go uh hired
whenever there is a rally there are a
lot of arbitrage between the platforms
and we're using some bots that we are
doing ourselves to actually take
advantage of this arbitrage and what we
want to do we want to do that with the
funds we get from here so once again we
need to check if we meet the sec
requirements we're going to check with
lawyers how to make it clean and we're
going to distribute all the profits to
you guys and to do some crazy things
with this product so it's only the
beginning as you can see guys we for now
don't have many followers on twitter so
retweet our pin comment guys follow us
on discord spread the word guys tell it
to everybody to your friends your family
guys this is our uh nft project yes this
is for you this is for the channel uh
this is gonna be i think the best nft
project we're gonna have this year guys
we're gonna make it epic i guarantee
that so spread the word follow us on our
social medias and help us to spread the
word i'm waiting for you guys there so
coming back to gme i'm pretty much done
guys here so unfortunately at 87 i think
we're gonna have a sending reaction
coming and then we're gonna probably uh
go lower i would say 65 is what we need
to see this week for best to be at least
satisfied this is where i personally
will take some of the profits i have uh
from my protection and then if we come
guys of course between 57 and 40 it's a
massive buy guys we're gonna probably
have a very strong bullish reaction here
so let's see what happens on the rest of
the market as well you guys know that
we're in a difficult situation jiren
powell is gonna talk tomorrow he's gonna
talk about uh the fed rate decision on
wednesday yes so tomorrow it's going to
be very important guys you know that
he's stuck in uh you know in a difficult
situation so let's see if the rate hike
is going to increase or if it's going to
slow down if you're going to be hotish
or dovish this of course going to have
an impact on gme guys so pre-market is
coming 83 years like i said so to sum up
the situation 87 probably gonna have a
selling reaction 65 58 uh our support
levels and fully the ultimate support
where if we get there guys i can tell
you i'm gonna load some shells so that's
it for me i hope you guys enjoyed this
video and if you did please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore i'll see you guys